mais moi je lui demande pas d'être
généreux du monde est président en
échange la république qui respecte les
principes de la république
je moi je considère que ce qu'il fait
sur les migrants comparable à la
déchéance de nationalité s'est remise en
cause d'un principe sacré de la
république c'est pas moins alors
peut-être que ça comme ce sont des
migrants comme l'on revive comme
aujourd'hui les migrants se dire
aujourd'hui ce qui fait le ciment social
de la nation fait la peur des migrants
et qu'elle est largement alimentée par
les ministres de l'intérieur les uns
après les autres à l'exception de
bernard cazeneuve qui était pas trop sur
ce discours là lui mais beaucoup
d'autres aujourd'hui sont soit un
discours qui est systématique de peur
des migrants bon moment je pense que
dans ces cas là il faut revenir aux
principes et les principes m'ordonne de
dire au nom des principes qui sont les
miens que aujourd'hui c'est indigne de
faire cela à quelques milliers de
personnes